[Música]
mientras rusia mantiene las tensiones
con occidente en torno a las amenazas de
invasión a ucrania el presidente
vladimir putin da también muestras de
expandir la influencia de su país en
nuestra región en américa latina' en ese
contexto habló con el presidente de
nicaragua daniel ortega también llamó a
los líderes de venezuela y cuba y
recibió al presidente de argentina
alberto fernández y hoy miércoles la
reunión fue con el presidente brasileño
jair bolsonaro a pesar de los esfuerzos
de rusia eeuu y china tienen vínculos
económicos mucho mayores y más fuertes
con américa latina' el kremlin solo
lleva ventaja con el apoyo de naciones
que se están quedando aisladas del
escenario global hablamos de venezuela
cuba y nicaragua para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestro primer invitado
del es vladimir rowinsky profesor de
ciencia política y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad icesi
esto en cali colombia que estudia la
relación entre rusia con américa latina'
gracias profesor por estar con nosotros
en este espacio de frank 74 llamado
directo américa la pregunta de sencilla
porque a vladimir putin quiera aumentar
su influencia
la tina cuáles son sus verdaderos
intereses en nuestra región
buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación el interés principal de rusia
américa latina tiene que ver con la
ubicación geográfica de nuestra región
somos vecinos de los eeuu y como ya
demostró la crisis las tensiones
alrededor de ucrania para rusia de
vladimir putin eeuu es el enemigo
político número uno y para la región de
américa latina las élites fosas están
aplicando la lógica de erez y propiedad
en otras palabras ellos quieren llevar a
cabo unas acciones recíprocas sobre todo
simbólicas
como respuesta a lo que ellos consideran
hacer washington en su barrio en el
barrio de rusia que es ucrania profesor
siendo así entonces ya para luego
desmenuzar esto esta respuesta de mi
primera pregunta le quiero preguntar el
papel de américa latina en este
conflicto entre occidente moscú y
ucrania
bueno yo creo que por primera vez
aquí en américa latina' nosotros
sentimos el impacto del conflicto de
manera más o menos directa y esto tiene
que ver con los anuncios de varios
funcionarios del gobierno ruso sobre la
posibilidad que eeuu se puede ampliar su
presencia militar en algunos países
latinoamericanos en respuesta a lo que
los eeuu están haciendo en ucrania según
la visión de vladimir putin a las élites
rusas y esto claramente ya termina con
una posición más o menos periférica de
américa latina en cuanto a las grandes
peleas que normalmente ocurrieron antes
fuera de américa latina y en europa en
asia o en algunas otras partes entonces
ahora puede ser que américa la que uno
no logra mantenerse al margen del
conflicto y yo creo que esto es
realmente lo que ha cambiado ahora
hablemos ahora el caso específico del
presidente de brasil jair bolsonaro
quien se encuentra en moscú
de moscú y que también políticamente
como ya es sabido por todos es más
aliado de eeuu que busca realmente el
visionario con esta visita a moscú esto
sería una especie de castigo a
washington digamos por las frías
relaciones con joe biden
de cierto modo si efectivamente es una
especie de castigo porque yo creo que
washington estaba ignorando durante una
buena parte de el año pasado pues las
relaciones directas con brasil y esto es
también una evidencia del papel que está
jugando a américa latina en las
relaciones entre
eeuu y rusia porque la visita de
bolsonaro moscú es un mensaje dirigido a
washington que yo creo que se debe leer
de la siguiente manera hay que cuidar
más a sus aliados en américa latina a
pesar de las diferencias que puedan
existir en la materia ideológica y
también lo hizo el presidente argentina
alberto fernández en su visita a moscú
dijo que quería digamos a 9 perder
depender tanto de eeuu en materia
comercial y buscar más alianzas con rusa
digamos que eso puede ser una tendencia
de lo que pasa con los líderes de
américa latina
con washington independientemente de su
ideología como lo estamos viendo por
ejemplo con el presidente jair bolsonaro
yo creo que el caso argentino es
distinto en comparación al caso de
brasil sin embargo los mensajes pueden
ver
pueden estar bastante
compartidos o los mensajes parecidos
precisamente mirando hacia américa
latina desde la perspectiva de la
reciprocidad simbólica y es importante
tener en cuenta que yo creo que rusia
está muy pendiente de los cambios que
pueden ocurrir en américa latina' en
este año sobre todo si pensamos de las
elecciones presenciales en colombia y en
brasil ahora también profesor es posible
que rusia esté buscando expandirse
militarmente en nuestra región américa
latina para así estar más cerca de
occidente y específicamente por supuesto
al lado de eeuu y de esta manera
posicionarse como una gran potencia
volver a posicionarse como una mega
potencia
sí yo creo que en fin de cuenta esto es
el objetivo uno de los objetivos estamos
hablando de que el mundo ahora vive los
cambios dramáticos el mundo está
cambiando mucho más rápido que antes en
este sentido en el contexto de cómo son
las relaciones internacionales ahora y
todo indica que vamos a ver por lo menos
en algún momento de la historia del
siglo 21 que viene
la nueva la vuelta de la política de las
grandes potencias y también él le quería
preguntar entonces el profesor pues ya
como una conclusión de nuestra
conversación y hablando de la pelea
digamos por quién es más aliado entre
entre washington y moscú digamos que
rusia entonces estaría posicionando como
más aliado de países latinoamericanos se
está enfriando más las relaciones con
washington que va a pasar ahí o si es
algo momentáneo o que va a perdurar en
el tiempo y realmente rusia entonces va
a ganar más terreno en nuestra región
como lo lee
bueno hay dos razones
para
este acercamiento de eeuu ser una de
estas razones y estoy mencionando ya que
tienen que ver con la lógica de la
reciprocidad y
parece que desde la perspectiva rusa hay
muy pocas esperanzas que las relaciones
entre moscú y washington puedan
mejorarse en algún momento en el futuro
cercano pero existe también
la motivación y esto tiene que ver con
algo que a veces se pasa desapercibido y
es la intención de rusia mantenerse como
la potencia superpotencia en materia de
energía si bien rusia tiene muchos
recursos energéticos propios pero los
recursos que rusia ahora está exportando
están ubicados en las zonas que fueron
desarrollados hace muchos años durante
los tiempos de la unión soviética y el
acceso a los nuevos yacimientos por
ejemplo de petróleo o de gas es muy
difícil hay que invertir mucho y su
manera infraestructura y por eso las
empresas rusas como por ejemplo la
empresa pública más grande del mundo
buscan adquirir acceso a la materia
energética en otros lugares donde la
infraestructura donde acceso fácil y
venezuela por ejemplo es uno de estos
casos entonces yo creo que vamos a ver
este doble intención de rusia por un
lado mantener la oportunidad para la
acción de recíproca y por otro lado
también aumentar la presencia en el
sector de la energía